- Let's do this.
Today is the day.
- [Mark] Arianna.
Arianna, where are you from?
Where'd you grow up?
- [Arianna] I was born
in Las Vegas Nevada,
but I was raised in South Central LA.
- [Mark] And tell me about your family.
You had both your parents as a kid?
- I'm Mexican, Cuban, and German.
My mom's side of the
family, they're Cubans,
but they're in Las Vegas.
I was raised with my Mexican family,
that's why I don't have my accent.
That's why I don't have a Cuban accent.
Mandala la pinga!
This is how they sound.
They have a little lingo to their word.
They have a little salsa in their words.
But, I didn't grow up with them,
so I didn't come out with the accent.
Spanish was my first language.
I learned English by school.
- [Mark] Oh, I see.
- I graduated high
school, John C. Fremont.
I went to college for one semester.
I took Criminal Investigation,
Psychology, Speech,
Police Organization, so I'm 10 steps ahead
of the organizations.
I'm what you call organized crime.
Don't take the pretty face for granted
because I'm more gangster than half
of these guys that carry straps
and guns and fucking drugs.
The streets made me.
I've been running these
streets for seven years.
- [Mark] You've been in a gang?
- Mm-hmm, the streets made me.
- [Mark] How old are you?
- I'm 26, but I feel 40.
I've been living in these streets
for seven years and I'm tired.
It ain't easy, they're cold.
- [Mark] Let me go back to your childhood.
How was your childhood?
- It was pretty gruesome.
My grandparents were strict.
My grandpa was straight from Mexico.
He'd beat me with
everything he could find.
Horse whips, sandals, branches
from the tree, his shoes.
One time I made my cousin
eat dog food by accident,
'cause I thought it was a Scooby Snack,
'cause I watched so much Scooby-Doo.
He made me eat the dog food
and I threw up all over myself.
One time I accidentally
stepped on my cousins hand,
and he made me put my hand on
the floor, and stepped on my hand.
He said, "How do you like that?"
He beat me every day.
I learned by getting beat.
He said, "Girls like you need to get beat
"in order to get learned."
So, he's from Mexico.
He taught me to tie my
shoelaces by beating me,
and if I didn't get it
right, the little bunny ears,
he would beat me every time.
Smack me.
Talking back hands, I'm
talking slaps to the face,
pulling on the hair.
And he had a little technique,
and he made me kneel on uncooked rice
for 30 minutes in a corner,
and that was my crucial punishment.
Straight from Mexico,
cold piece of work, bro.
One time I said something like,
"Ain't that a piece of shit
that my grandpa kicked me out,"
and then I asked him to come
back home, and he said no,
'cause he found a condom
under my mattress,
and found out that I was
fucking when I was 18.
He said, "I thought you was a virgin."
"You're no longer my granddaughter."
"I lost ownership of you."
"I don't respect you, you're a hoe."
He said, "You're out here 18
years old and you're fucking?"
"You call yourself a
woman, cause you're getting
"dicked down at 18 years old?"
"You're not my granddaughter."
So he kicked me out, and
I left when I was 18.
I said as soon as I turn 18, I'm leaving,
and it's what I did.
I've been in the streets ever since.
- [Mark] Where did you go at 18?
- Hmm?
- [Mark] What did you start doing at 18?
- Prostituting, I joined
gang-banging when I was 21.
I joined Florencia 13.
My dad's from there, my
uncles are from there.
I got beat with a crowbar one day,
Watts up, fuck Flowers,
by my enemies from Warrentown, Watts.
They want me dead because
I put them in the pen.
They call me a snitch.
I asked my older homies,
"Does that make me a snitch,
"if I put a guy in jail,
"instead of dirtying my hands myself?"
He said "No, because he was a man,
"and you didn't deserve that,
"and he should have had
his homegirls handle that."
So, there's a price on my head.
I told this guy from Watts,
"If you get a phone call says
"we want her dead, tie her up
"until we get there and
we'll take it from there,
"would you do it?"
He said, "Hell yeah I would,
"'cause you got a big-ass mouth."
I'm the type of person
that needs the last word.
I don't shut up if
people say shut up bitch!
'Cause I'm not a bitch,
I got a God given name
and it's Ari-fuckin-anna.
Ariana Grande?
Nah, 'cause I ain't famous.
Arianna la chicita del barrio.
That means the little one from the hood.
Julia Roberts, the high
cheekbones and smile.
Yeah, Pretty Woman?
A baby prostitute, that's what I was.
That's what I became.
Since I was a little girl,
aw you look like Julia!
I said, "Really that woman
who plays a prostitute?"
That's what I became.
I saw the movie once
and I got the message.
Make your money.
What's in between is your price position.
So I made my money.
I met a pimp named A1, from Crips.
I got my ass beat because
I messed with a guy
from Florence 'til he beat me
with an extension 'til I bled,
'cause I took my pimp to his house.
He lied and said he wanted tattoo work,
and he heard him saying,
"We're going to put her back to work,
"we're going to give her this dress,
"we're going to beat her up and
send her back on the track."
Soldier on my chest, Florencia 13.
The KMT Watts shot him.
He's zipped up.
That's when they shoot you
and they have to zip up your stomach.
They chunked him up.
They blew him up so hard,
they had to take chunks of his thigh
to put it on his stomach.
He was in the hospital
with a tube in his mouth on life support.
He barely lived by chance.
I love him, but I hate him,
because he beat me and
I didn't deserve that.
People take my kindness for weakness.
I used to be very nice,
but I became a ruthless
and cold piece of work.
And I'm thug-bitch the to the fullest.
I am harder than half of
these guys who carry straps
and fucking crystal meth and a pipe.
They tell you they gangster.
Naw bro.
Get your ass beat.
Get mistaken for a fucking informant.
Get tied up.
Get your cell phone taken
away and get almost burned
with a straightener, because
they think you're snitching.
I said, "Bro, I got F13, if I'm a snitch
"my own homies would've killed me."
I said, I got the job
offered to me, informant.
I gave the cops my number.
I said I'll think about it.
I said, "Will my homies know about this?"
They said, "If you don't want them to,
"we could do it undercover."
"Let us know there's guns
"in the house and we'll get you back in."
I got fucking hit in the face
by a Ty Cobbing-ass bitch.
I ain't even been to the Dodgers' Stadium,
and I got hit with a
Dodgers bat in my face
by a Ty Cobbing-ass bitch
named Crystal Garcia.
She's still alive.
That's where I'm fucking up.
The bitch was dead.
The bitch is dead to me.
Lawndale, she made me homeless again.
It took a long time to
get back on my feet.
I met this white boy named Sneaky
from Lawndale, fucking lock.
That's how he dissing me.
I'll take his whole team out.
Looks like Paul Walker with no teeth,
slammed back on heroin.
I said, "Oh gee, you know somewhere
"I can smoke my pipe, get off my feet?"
Man, I'm in Gardena, 'cause
I got jumped by the Hoovers.
Remember me, bitch?
I took a shower, a black
gangster from Hoovers.
I know she was my enemy, but
I played with fire that day.
She jumped me later that night
with two other black girls.
Threw me on a two bed mattress
and broke cabinets on me.
I have a bone sticking out,
because I ended up in the ER that night.
They didn't stop beating me.
I was yelling for my life.
Nobody jumped in.
Same thing with the Warrentown KMT Watts.
I was in a dress and chocolates
and I took a Paisa to buy some dope.
But I took them to my hood,
that's where I fucked up.
'Cause my hood and my
homies don't even claim me.
They just said to my dad.
He said, "Whoever put
my daughter in the hood,
"better take her ass out."
They said, "Naw G, she
ain't from the hood,
"we busted a train on her."
Choo-choo!
Only three of them showed.
50 or more have to show.
Let's fuck this bitch in the hood.
I would have been looser than a goose.
Aflac!
Like a fucking goose.
I didn't do it.
I condoned in it, coulda
happened to me, but it didn't.
My luck I guess.
But I didn't even get a real initiation,
and I bang to the fullest.
My dad's from there, my
uncles are from there.
So I'm Florence bound, regardless
if I got a tattoo or not.
As small as it is, F13, the
world's most notorious gang.
Gangland, search us.
Florencia trece.
I'm Mexican, Cuban, and German.
Three races and I'm crazy.
People take my pretty face for granted,
and the streets made me.
So like I said, as pretty as
I am, don't ever cross me,
'cause if you do, I will
get you 10 times worse,
and don't say I didn't warn you.
People put me in their car,
smoke me out and then fuck me over.
Tell me get the fuck on.
In Fontana, I had a black
man sit on my chest.
Put my hand on a Bible,
and I'll tell nothing but the truth.
He sat on my chest.
He said, "Bitch if you don't
suck my dick I'll kill you,"
with a strap on my head.
I don't know how I got away,
but maybe God looked out that time.
But if God existed,
half the shit I been through
wouldn't have happened.
So I became Illuminati, I
sold my soul to the devil.
I'm a devil worshiper.
Then I prayed to another
one called Santa Muerte.
It's a grim reaper of a skeleton.
Bejeweled red eyes like Medusa.
She turns you into stone,
now she touches you, you're dead.
It's a type of devil worshiping,
but she's called the saint of death.
It's a Mexican thing.
More of the Salvadorians,
more of a cartel thing.
All you got to do is worship
her, say a prayer or two,
light a candle, put some things
that are valuable to you,
like rings, goodies, treats.
In prison it's the most known thing,
for Santa Muerte, worshiping.
Prison people have her in a statue.
She has a grim reaper.
She has the hoodie.
She had bejeweled red eyes
like stones, like fugazis.
But they're red, but they're not fugazis.
They're bejeweled red eyes.
You look her in the eyes, you're dead.
All I got to do is make a prayer
and wish you were dead,
and she gonna get you.
One touch, you're dead.
Oh please, I want them dead, and I pray,
and I give her a good
reason why to kill you,
and you're dead, bro.
It's called playing with witchcraft.
It's called devil worshiping.
It's called witch hunt.
It's like when girls put love spells
and guys light a candle.
If you let a guy eat you out
when you're on your period,
as soon as he tastes your
blood, it's like a vampire.
He falls in love instantly.
As soon as you let a guy
hit raw, you're tight,
he falls in love with the pussy.
He gives you anything you want.
Drugs, takes you shopping,
gives you a house.
Says, "As long as you don't steal from me,
"you want something, ask for it."
"But if I find something in your pocket,
"don't say I didn't warn you."
So that's where your backhand and where
your ass-whooping is going to go.
My ex-boyfriend swears
that I snitched on him.
When he beat me with an extension cord,
the cops wanted me to
testify against court.
They subpoenaed me.
I got the subpoena.
I looked at it, threw it to the side.
I didn't show up to court,
because I was high off
crystal methamphetamine.
That's my drug of choice.
But I use any drug out there.
Anything I get my hands on.
PCP, up to the new drug nowadays that's
10 times harder than heroin.
I overdosed over once in MacArthur Park.
- [Mark] On fentanyl?
- Fentanyl, it's called China white,
the street name, black China.
It's a white substance.
It looks like crystal and crack cocaine.
But you could tell the difference,
'cause they all have like
a different tone to it, and a smell.
- [Mark] You're still using today?
- Yeah.
I just smoked a bowl earlier.
- [Mark] And you're five months pregnant?
- My mom did it, why can't I?
What makes me a bad person?
My baby going live, retarded
or not, I'm gonna love it.
My mom fucked me up.
I came out with severe depression,
bipolar schizophrenia, and anxiety.
I need 10 pills to calm me
down, but I'd rather use drugs,
'cause crystal meth calms me down.
I'm a dope baby.
Crystal meth is in my body.
Instead of using those 10 pills,
I self-prescribe with crystal meth.
I smoke it, I slam it, I sniff
it, and I turkey baste it.
Turkey baste is when they put it
in your asshole with a syringe.
Put a little bit of water
or else you just shart it.
But that burns your asshole,
It's like putting a razor up your ass.
If it's cuddy, it's going
to burn your asshole.
I had to put Vaseline on me earlier,
because I put a shard this fucking big,
and I didn't think it was that good.
My asshole felt like it was on fire,
like if I got pepper
sprayed in the fucking ass.
- [Mark] Do you know who
the father of your child is?
- His name is.
(name censored)
Yes I do.
- [Mark] And do you have
a relationship with him?
- As far as we know,
we're just having the kid.
- [Mark] Is he one of your customers?
- Huh?
- He's just my baby daddy.
- [Mark] Oh, I see.
- He's just the father of my child.
He says I'll be there for my child,
but I can't be with you,
because you got no respect.
You fucked other men.
He said, "You fucked other men
with my kid in your stomach."
I said, "My baby needed dimples."
I kept it funny 'cause I
take nothing but a joke.
Because if I take half of the
things that happened to me
serious in life, I'd be somewhere
in Chowchilla, upstate,
in the women's prison.
I went to prison once for
a probation violation.
I didn't even do nothing.
I didn't even commit a crime.
I just didn't check in with
my AB109, in San Bernardino,
when I fucked with the Verdugos.
See this pretty little
scar above my eyebrow?
He tried to pick up a prostitute,
say we're going to have a threesome.
Wasn't asking me, was telling
me, "You're going to do this."
"Which one do you want?"
Said, "It ain't happening."
Pulled his wheel so quick
when he tried to stop for one,
and I pulled and his car went
(car braking)
(smacking)
I got punched in the face.
(name censored)
I don't mind keeping these people's names.
So they know when I tell my story,
the motherfuckers are all
going to be put on guard.
These motherfuckers know
I ain't telling no lies.
And I don't make up stories.
I tell nothing but the
truth and only the truth,
'cause I don't got to make up shit.
My God-given word is my God-given word.
I don't gotta make up
shit or put extras on it,
because I tell it like it is,
regardless or not, I'm telling the truth.
You know what you did, so
own up to it, motherfucker,
or should I say mother lover.
Go fuck your mom.
Blue face, go fuck your mom.
Shake that ass little baby.
Da-da's cute, right?
That's what I'm gonna tell
him, go fuck your mom,
when they try to fuck with me again.
'Cause where I fuck up is where,
I need something like a
place to stay for a night,
a bowl that I can afford,
and I come begging these
motherfuckers for another chance.
I give them the right
to fuck me over again.
You ever heard the phrase
don't bite the hand that feeds you?
Or don't shit where you eat?
And don't rob from your peoples?
Apparently some people are too high
on drugs and use that as an excuse.
You can be higher than a kite,
tell me you don't know right from wrong.
Stealing and asking
permission is one thing.
You want something, ask for it.
It'll hurt if they say no,
but it don't hurt to ask.
I get off better by asking people.
But I do have a habit
of doing things or borrowing
things without asking,
then I'll turn them in last minute.
They wouldn't even know
the thing was gone.
I go here goes your portable,
your flashlight and this and this.
He's like when the fuck did you take this?
Oh the other day when
I was here, remember?
He goes, what the fuck?
You're good.
I go my bad, at least I
brought it back, right?
It would have hurt you more,
if I didn't bring it back.
You didn't even know it was
gone, so where's the miss there?
That part.
But Ty Cobb wanted to play,
and that was me getting hit
in the face with a Dodger bat.
I became homeless, recently,
six months ago, before my pregnancy.
She hit me in the face with
a bat and closed the door.
Had a knot this big,
the size of a golf ball.
Some Indian looking-bitch with a big nose.
She had the balls to punch a window in.
But she wouldn't punch me,
'cause she knows she
would've got her ass beat.
As small as I am, as pretty as I am,
I will beat the dog shit out of somebody.
'Cause I used to take kickboxing,
and I know street fighting.
Protect.
Kick.
High-knee, kick-knee, face
first, punch 'em in the stomach.
Punch gut.
That's the weakness, they go, "Ooh,"
and that takes the air out of them.
The bigger they are, the harder they fall.
So I don't care.
You could be 62 and I
will still beat you up.
See how quick you fall.
People think because they're men,
and because they got muscles,
that I'm intimidated by them.
But I'm not.
My name is Arianna Frances Medina,
I'm 26 years old, but I feel like 40,
'cause I've been running
the streets for seven,
and I've been gang-banging for five.
I had a fake initiation where I had
three gang members from
Florencia fuck me into the hood.
There's a such thing as
getting fucked in the hood,
but it needs to be 50 members involved.
Attendance was poor.
Only three of them showed,
but I fucked them into individual times.
Different times.
They claim to bust a train on me.
Did that once.
I got respect.
I did involve into an orgy one time.
I was smoking the hookah,
I swear to God they
laced it with something.
I wouldn't have did some orgy
with some Paisas in a parking lot.
My friend, my brody, brody is
another word like a bestie,
but it's more of a guy and a girl.
My brody used to have a
best friend named Laurel.
He chose a girl over his best friend.
He told me to kick rocks
because him and his girlfriend
were going to make up.
Threw me out of the trailer like
at three in the morning in HP.
And he had a case of what
you call elephantiasis.
It's when your intestines
swell up really big.
It's a health issue.
He showed me his balls and I freaked.
I didn't want to fuck him.
I left him in the Momo that night.
I walked all night,
and I met some guys in a
parking lot, smoking a hookah.
It's an instant, you just smoke.
But, I would have never involved myself,
or cooperated in a 10 man orgy.
I called it a dick fiesta.
I made it fun.
I made it seem like I did
know what I was doing.
I didn't know what I was participating in.
And he said, "If we grab a box of condoms
"would you fuck all of us?"
I said, "Sure would."
But that's after I hit the hookah.
So, I swear to God, so
help me God that I'm lying,
that they laced it with something.
Crystal meth maybe,
crack cocaine possibly,
fentanyl, it wasn't even out
by the time that happened.
This happened years ago.
I met a pimp named A1 and I
started working on Figueroa.
Figueroa was was where
the prostitutes work.
They stand in the corner butt naked.
Difference between me and them
is I didn't stand butt naked.
I earned my shit.
I'll stand in booty shorts,
chocolates and a little
cute outfit, tank top.
One time I was stripped butt
naked by the Pomo Crips.
They snatched my chain.
Whoa, whoa, shots fired.
I've been holding that in for dear life.
I farted.
It's so disgusting.
It's disrespectful.
I can't even hold it into pregnancy.
And that was the tacos I ate.
I'm basking in the ambience.
You can probably keep it,
it'll make people laugh.
It's a blooper.
I farted, sorry.
I've been holding it in for dear life.
- [Mark] I'll take it out if you like.
- Shots fired.
10-4, man down.
- [Mark] We'll talk about
it when you're done.
- Okay, basking in the ambience.
It got me, it got me, it was crucial.
- [Mark] That was very cute.
- It was like death.
It just hit me in the
face, was disrespectful.
- [Mark] You're pregnant.
- Yeah, that fart.
Excuse me, it's embarrassing,
so I'm turning red.
- [Mark] You get all kinds of breaks,
because you're pregnant.
- Yeah, it's like I bring it.
- [Mark] No sweat.
- If I would've lifted up my leg,
that would have been a nasty one.
- [Mark] All good.
- With the effort I've
been holding it in so long.
- [Mark] You were talking
about work in Figueroa.
- Yeah, walking in Figueroa, right?`
Some guy saw me, he picked me up
and said, "Let's make some money."
So what do I gotta do?
"All you gotta do is say you're my bitch."
"You work for me, and you
give me half of your money."
"I sit in the corner and I watch you,
"if I see anything sketchy, I got a gun."
"Let me take it from there."
So I did it 'til I met a guy named Soldier
from Florence and I left it.
But once you leave
prostitution, you can never
leave it because you'll
fall into temptation,
and just go back to the money.
It's so addicting, the money's so fast,
and it comes and goes.
So, they see a Mexican girl out there.
'Cause usually see nothing but
blacks, Chinese, white girls.
It's often that you see
a Mexican girl out there.
So they seen a Mexican girl out there,
oh yeah, they were pulling
over, you best believe.
Every five minutes, I wouldn't
even walk for three minutes.
Car pulls up.
I had white men, black men,
Chinese men, all types of men.
I got a $50 tip for letting a
black man eat me out, fuck me,
and have me in Momo for hours.
I didn't charge by the
time, I charged by the job.
50 for head, 80 for sex,
and 150 for everything,
talking asshole and everything included.
But I only let my boyfriend
fuck me in the asshole.
So, oral was mandatory,
but only with a condom.
'Cause STDs exist and mouth
diseases are disgusting.
I only suck my boyfriend's
dick with no condoms.
But where I fucked up one day
was where I fucked my
ex-boyfriend's best friend,
he gave me syphilis.
Thank God it was curable,
but those two penicillin
shots to my ass hurt.
It's a thick white
substance, it cures you.
But where the shit is, is
that I'm not even cured yet.
I heard, even though if
I got those two shots,
my body still has to detox from it.
They said even though
you got those two shots
you're not in the clear yet.
It's still in your body.
You still need to go through some process,
take medication or something.
I haven't found out yet,
but I'm not gonna lie,
I had unprotected with my enemies,
and I gave it to them,
and I don't regret it.
That's cold piece of work,
but Watts up, fuck flowers, right?
That's me getting back
at you motherfuckers,
for your homies from Watts,
and I don't care what Watts or not.
West, south, two differences.
What's the tension between
the East and the West?
And Tupac's always talking
about fuck your wife,
but not in those exact words.
Oh, I love Tupac.
- [Mark] So Arianna, are you concerned
about the future of your child?
You're living here.
You're homeless.
You're living a very rough lifestyle.
- I'm homeless.
I'm gang-banging and I kick it
with nothing but my enemies,
and I play with fire all day.
Ask not to be burned, play with the devil,
you're gonna get it.
Play no games.
You're asking the devil,
if there's any spirits in the house,
please make yourself be known.
Throw something.
Touch me, make your presence be known.
I'm opening the portal to the death.
Death.
People are known as spirits
because they're good.
Spirits and ghosts are
two different things.
Demons are people who
can accept their death,
and are lonely zombies.
Just walk around on Earth,
unless you say a prayer, say
I'm praying for this person.
Example, Arianna Frances Medina,
when I die and I can't accept my death,
someone has to say a prayer, say my name,
and say please let this
person accept their death,
and let them know that they're dead,
and they're no longer going
to ever be in a human body,
and are just a spirit now.
Please let them move on,
let their spirit rest in peace,
and let them know that they're dead,
and accept the fact that they're dead.
Because some people die so fast
and they're in denial that they're dead.
And they're called lonely
zombies, walking on the Earth.
Those are demons.
Demons are people who are
mad because they died.
They don't want to accept they've died.
People will get tied up
and thrown in ditches like prostitutes.
That's where I put myself.
- [Mark] What's the most valuable lesson
you've learned all your
years on the street?
- When I had the man sit
on my chest in Fontana
with a strap to my head and said,
"Bitch if you don't suck
my dick I'll kill you,"
I don't know how I got away,
but that day I jumped a brick wall.
I'm not Spiderman.
That brick wall is as tall
as that gate right there.
The adrenaline made me jump that wall.
I was grateful that I got away.
If he would've pulled the
trigger, I would've been dead.
I wouldn't be telling my story now.
I wouldn't have even
made it to 26 years old.
26, will I live to see 27?
I don't know.
By the way things are going,
people say I'm not gonna last long.
Yesterday I was yelling Watts
up, fuck flowers, right?
You guys hate me.
You guys got me, bro.
Please, somebody kill me.
Do me the favor.
'Cause I'd rather be dead
than deal with life,
because life is crucial.
I've always been by myself.
People don't tolerate me
more than a day or two.
They get rid of me.
Because I could be making money,
but instead I'm out here
smoking drugs, wasting my life.
Rotting away like a good
piece of forbidden fruit.
Quick joke, my boyfriend's a twin.
His twin looks better than him.
I picked the wrong one.
His friend told me,
"Tell John I said his twin
brother's the forbidden fruit."
Oh God!
I said, "That's where
you're right, homegirl."
I picked the wrong twin.
His twin has hair, has
teeth, lives in a house,
in a shack somewhere with
his mother, and eats.
My baby daddy's in an RV,
slammed back on heroin, smoking crystal.
Then fucks with the bitches,
and then gets beat like
a dog when I find out,
because he has the nerve
to neglect it in my face.
But I found a dick ring, and
a fucking condom in his room,
and he still had the nerve to deny it.
Some bitch said, "Oh
Jenny, I love you, Jenny."
I called her phone.
I said "Listen here, bitch."
"My dick."
"He's my baby father."
"If I find out where you live,
"I will locate you so fucking quick,
"and beat the dog shit out of you."
"You leave John alone."
"That's my baby's father and my dick."
He has a checkmate.
The Nike sign tattooed on
his dick, bolded as fuck.
Whoever did that gay as fuck.
Faggot.
Because my baby daddy thought he had dick,
I could sell my pussy and
make more money than him,
and make him feel like he's something.
Right that part.
My baby daddy is five-four.
And I beat him already three times,
I gave him three little,
pretty black eyes.
He made a joke one time.
Picked a fight that he
couldn't fucking win,
with a five-five and a half big mama.
Size matters.
'Cause by an inch or two,
I will still beat the
dog shit out of you, bro.
Sneaky Fernando thought he was thug.
White boy I'ma keep it G-real,
you could you drop off
your kid and run that fade.
'Cause you're going to learn that day.
- [Mark] So Arianna, what
would you say to your family,
if they, let's say they watch this video,
what would you say to them?
- I got a little emotional
there because my family,
they barely even let me see them.
I love them.
They still answer my phone calls.
If I go to jail, they
put money on my books.
Honestly, if you're watching this,
sorry it's the hormones in the pregnancy.
I love you.
I finally was able to tell my story,
so when I die, I'm
leaving something behind.
And sorry that I had to
prostitute and disrespect myself.
And dad, F's up dad,
except that I'm in the hood, bro,
I've been gang-banging for 21.
And I'm harder than half of
these guys that claim Florence.
Florencia gang member, dad,
I got beat up with a crowbar.
Watts up, fuck flowers.
Flower, when I'm dead,
put my money in the grave.
I love you, dad.
Mom, you never were in my life.
You lied to me.
You said you were a recovered
addict to get me to get
on a bus and meet you
in Las Vegas, Nevada.
Fuck you mom, but I love you.
I say it out of love, but
you're a cold bitch for that.
I hate both of my parents,
'cause they just had me and
threw me out in the world
and said, "You're on your own, daughter."
My brothers and sisters were in DCFS.
I'm not even gonna
pursue looking for them,
because I don't know where to go.
I just know three of my brothers,
two of my half brothers from
same dad, different mom.
My dad cheated on his
girlfriend and had me.
That's a pretty story.
That's how I was made.
Cheating scandal.
I didn't ask to be born, but I'm here now,
and I'm living to the fullest.
And one day my story
will inspire other girls.
I know life is hard,
but there ain't no such thing as
making it out of the rock bottom.
You fall down, you pick yourself up.
You're a lady.
Don't take men for granted.
Don't take money.
Don't do drugs, because
drugs are very bad,
and they're addicting.
As much as I would have
known that I was a dope baby,
and as soon as I hit that
drug that first time,
I was going to get highly addicted,
I would've never picked it up.
But one time I was smoking weed,
and my homeboy from Florencia.
There was one homeboy, right?
Passed me the pipe,
and said, "Hey homegirl,
you wanna hit this?"
I said, "What is it?"
He said, "It's called crystal meth."
"It's called the G pipe."
Dope.
I hit it one time and I got addicted.
I couldn't let it go.
Every time I see someone
hitting it, I start shaking.
It's called feening for it.
My body says, get it, get
it, get it, pick it up.
I begged for drugs.
I sell my ass for drugs.
And I deal with dumbasses
that put my hands
in the enemy's mouth.
Jumping a shark tank,
expecting to have a hand left
when the sharks chew me up.
But like I said, my family.
I don't blame them for giving up on me.
There's so many times I've
said I'm going to rehab.
But it's easy saying it,
but it's not easy doing it.
But, the streets are my motivation.
I stay in the streets because
it's my daily program.
It's like me living in the pen.
I'm institutionalized, if I get out there.
You ever seen that movie where
that black guy hangs himself
because he was institutionalized,
and once they let him go,
and he was free, he didn't
know how to develop himself,
and settle with society.
So he hanged himself.
That's me.
If I leave the streets and I go
in the house and I pretend to
be normal, I'll kill myself.
I can't.
My life will never be normal.
Gang-banging, drugs, and
prostitution is what I learned.
And that's my story.
And cut.
- [Mark] Thank you, Arianna.